nos dicen utiliza la herramienta de
reflexión para definir una reflexión que
mapa al triángulo efe
en el otro triángulo de abajo este
triángulo de azul
efe n es el que tenemos que definir le
una línea de reflexión para poder mapear
lo a este otro triángulo de aquí vamos a
ver qué herramientas nos dan
reflexión sobre la recta de él aquí hay
una coordenada a esta otra coordenada y
eso lo que tenemos que encontrar dos
puntos que dibujen la línea de reflexión
para hacer lo que nos piden en la
gráfica vamos a pasarnos a la
herramienta de dibujo para encontrar la
línea de reflexión queremos ubicar el
punto uno a este otro punto de aquí el
punto uno lo voy a poner aquí con este
color como dorado y su correspondiente
reflejo acá y como es una línea de
reflexión nos basta con ubicar dos
puntos aunque aquí tenemos varios puntos
o varios vértices con los que trabajar
vamos a elegir este otro el n me
interesa ubicar este punto n de aquí a
este punto de acá y para que cualquier
punto de la figura tenga su
correspondiente punto en la imagen
reflejada ambos deben ser equidistantes
a la línea de reflexión este punto y
este punto son equidistantes a la línea
de reflexión
igual que estos dos puntos de aquí otra
forma de pensar en esto es que la línea
de reflexión debe contener todos los
puntos intermedios entre estas dos
figuras vamos a calcularla esto lo
haremos con algo de matemáticas vamos a
ver cuáles son las coordenadas de este
vértice y su respectivo reflejo tenemos
este vértice un este está en las
coordenadas veamos x es menos 2
- 2,10
8 - 28 entonces lo vamos a notar de este
lado la coordenada menos 2,8 y queremos
ver también cuál es la coordenada de su
reflejo este punto está en x menos
5 menos 5,5 menos 55 voy a escribirlo en
otro color este del reflejo está en
menos 5,5
cuál es el punto intermedio entre estos
dos puntos pues para encontrarlo basta
con calcular el promedio de las equis y
el promedio de las es vamos a hacer
entonces aquí tengo para calcular la
equis de esta coordenada intermedia voy
a promediar este menos dos con este
menos cinco menos dos más menos cinco
entre dos coma
el promedio de las es que va a ser 8 más
entre dos este va a ser mi promedio muy
bien vamos a hacerlo - 2 - 5 va a ser
menos 7 menos 7 entre 2 va a ser igual a
menos 3.5 y 8 5 es igual a 13 13 entre 2
es igual a 6.5 esta es la coordenada de
el punto intermedio entre este punto y
su reflejo ahora encontramos otro punto
de la recta de reflexión
vamos a usar esta coordenada n y su
reflejo así que este punto n se
encuentra en x2
2,16 y su punto reflejo tiene la
coordenada x 9 y 12 1 y en 191 esta es
la otra coordenada vamos a notar las
aquí tengo la coordenada 2
menos 6 y la coordenada 9,1 queremos
encontrar el punto medio entre estos dos
puntos estos de aquí así que vamos a
promediar las equis y a promediar las 10
me quedan
29 entre 2 para sacar el promedio coma
menos 6 + 1
entre 2
92 es 11 11 entre 2 nos da 5.5 5.5 y
menos 6 más 1 es menos 5 menos 5 entre 2
es igual a menos 2.5 este es otro punto
en nuestra línea de reflexión con este
punto y este otro punto puedo dibujar mi
línea de reflexión vamos a ubicar el
primer punto está en menos 3.5 es menos
uno menos dos menos 3.5 va a estar aquí
a la mitad la equis y 6.5 así que me voy
aquí arriba seis puntos cinco por aquí
está
este punto de la línea de reflexión y
sin como ven está intermedio entre estos
dos puntos y este otro de aquí este otro
punto vamos a ponerlo de otro color se
encuentra en la coordenada x 5.5
aquí tenemos 5.5 y menos 2.5 entonces de
5.5 bajó a menos 2.5 aquí está y si yo
uno estos dos puntos tendré mi línea de
reflexión vamos a hacerlo voy a ponerlo
en
un color que se note entonces tomó este
punto lo uno con este otro por aquí y
para continuar lo voy a tomar de nuevo
esta línea y la voy a seguir hacia abajo
para que se note
esta es mi línea de reflexión esto tiene
sentido ya que vemos que si tomamos
cualquier punto arbitrario de la figura
no sé por ejemplo se me ocurre el punto
que está aquí este de acá
y lo reflejamos sobre esta línea busco
la distancia más corta entre este punto
y esta línea que sería más o menos algo
así si continúo
siguiendo esta línea me voy a topar aquí
en este otro lado su correspondiente
punto en la imagen reflejo y esto tiene
sentido ya que ambas imágenes son como
el reflejo en un espejo de cualquier
manera encontramos los dos puntos que
definen esta línea de reflexión y ahora
regresemos al ejercicio para escribir
estos puntos y de acuerdo con los
cálculos que acabamos de hacer entonces
aquí podemos poner el punto menos 3.5
coma
6.5 y este otro punto que calculamos es
5.5 coma menos 2.5 y si se fijan aquí
nos está marcando ya estos puntos de
nuestro triángulo fn vamos a
visualizarlo nos está marcando puntos en
nuestros vértices quiere decir que ya
encontramos nuestra línea de reflexión
sólo nos falta comprobar la respuesta y
es correcta